[Musique]
une critique sociale extrêmement
violentes contre le du peuple si vous
voulez contre l'aristocratie en nous
rapprochant le plus possible de la
manière dont le mozart
éventuellement tu entendes tout ça tout
ça va être une sorte de représentation
moderne n'ont pas de l'authenticité à
l'ancienne mais tout simplement
d'essayer de retrouver les qualités de
couleurs de l'équipe d'articulation et
l'expression du xviiie siècle
[Musique]
l'opéra et par la paire nature un genre
qui n'est pas simple parce que
il ya des chanteurs il ya beaucoup trop
d'éléments qui sont ensemble pour que ça
marche mais par toujours en général le
miracle a toujours vieux et donc en
s'aperçoit que c'est un c'est au
contraire une oeuvre d'art totale vit
mélange de le chant la musique la mise
en scène de théâtre les décors les
costumes les pieds
[Musique]
pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas l'occasion
d'aller à l'opéra venait à l'opéra
justement c'est le moment de c'est le
moment de sortir de chez vous puis
justement dans les circonstances
présentes où il semble que le variant
soit soit - 1 - comme moins dangereux
vous pouvez venir bien protégés et vous
aurez un spectacle qui vous réjouir à
coeur
[Musique]